last week I told you that more and more
Republicans are just quitting politics
in the Trump era some don't want to be
Republicans under Trump some are worried
that they're going to lose their
re-elections and want to retire and save
some face even and historically pretty
reliably red districts and last week I
told you about a few of them we had
Republican congressman Mike Conaway I
told you about Paul Mitchell who's
bailing Pete Olsson Martha Roby Rob
Bishop Republican members of Congress
I've already spoken previously about
Senator Jeff Flake Senator Jeff Flake
was a Republican from the state of
Arizona
he ended up bailing pretty clearly
because of disgust with the Republican
Party under Donald Trump that was a seat
Democrats were able to take Kyrsten
Sinema ultimately won Jeff Flake seats
so this stuff matters and there's now
two more okay Congressman Kenny
marshawn's is saying bye-bye and
quitting this is in Texas and this one
matters sort of extra because this is
the Dallas area the 24th congressional
district Democrats have done better and
better in recent election cycles there
were some pre 2018 election cycles where
Democrats got between 32 and 37% of the
vote in the 24th district in 2018 it was
closer than it had been in a really long
time Jan MacDowell the Democratic
challenger received 47% of the vote
barely losing to the Republican Kenny
marshawn's so that's a great district
for Democrats to target Democrats are
targeting it this is not an out of reach
district that will obviously go to a
Republican that's really good news we
then also learned a few days ago that
will Hurd Hur D also from Texas is
quitting he will not be seeking
re-election his district is a border
district he also won re-election by
fewer than five points in 2018 and in
that district it worked out to just a
few hundred votes based on voter turnout
so that's another district that will be
open and will be in play for Democrats
in 2020 so there are now 12 Republicans
12 Republicans who are not running for
re-election in twenty
20 this is very good for Democrats
incumbent Republicans are much more
likely to be helped by a Republican
president running for re-election that's
Trump in 2020 open seats are more likely
to be fights when you have two new
challengers or candidates I guess we
would call them the Senate reality
remains that it's very unlikely
Democrats are going to take the Senate
in 2020 I got some interesting emails so
I've been saying for months now as you
may know or you may not know and that's
okay there are a hundred senators and a
third of them are up for re-election
every two years since they are six-year
terms it just so happens that the slate
of senators up for re-election in 2020
is not favorable to Democrats I don't
really see a path for Democrats to take
the Senate in 2020 last week I asked for
people to write in if you thought there
is a way for Democrats to take the
Senate and I got a couple of emails from
people talking about
well if doug jones is able to may retain
his seat in alabama
and then in colorado the election goes
one way and a couple people put together
scenarios but they are definitely uphill
battles but if in the house we see an
expanded Democratic majority in 2018
thanks in part to some of these
Republicans quitting a bigger house
majority sets up Democrats to be better
positioned in 2022 for the Senate
showdown where Democrats actually could
retake control of the Senate which of
course would be massive if Trump is
removed in 2020 Democrats expand control
of the house in 2020 and then take
control in 2022 that period between
January of 2023 and January of 2025
could be massive in terms of actual
positive possibilities that's why this
stuff matters this is why midterms
matter Republicans are now on the
defensive after losing the house in 2018
they're in danger of falling even
further behind they are now potentially
endangering their Senate majority just
two years later and Texas is
increasingly a target
no longer solid red but we've got to run
these elections correctly every single
one now
Wow I will have more detailed reports
for you about particular districts the
target we actually are starting to line
up some interviews with some interesting
district level races House races for
2020 I'll be talking about what you can
do as we get closer to 2020 for maximum
impact focusing not on really safe blue
districts but on the ones that we might
be able to take from Republicans and we
will also be talking about this
extensively in the context of Democrats
have to get it together at the local
politics level I've been talking about
this for years Democrats just aren't
good at a lot of things one is local
grassroots races state legislatures
state Senate's as an example we will be
talking about that because that matters
as well it's not just representatives in
Washington that determine the political
slant of the country and within states
but it's what's happening in state
legislatures as well so we're going to
talk about that now we're also going to
talk more broadly about continuing to
talk about the other areas that really
impact this gerrymandering and
districting and that relates to the
census voter suppression so on and so on
you probably know all of that one of the
things I would love to talk about
tonight during my live stream on Twitch
at 6:30 p.m. Eastern Time which I hope
you'll join me for our specific races
that you're paying attention to okay so
I hope you'll join me this evening 6:30
p.m. Eastern twitch.tv slash David
Pakman make sure you're following me
there make sure if you have Amazon Prime
that you sign up for free with twitch
Prime we get paid it costs you nothing
and I'll meet you there at 6:30 p.m.
Eastern this evening